But as we turn now to God's word, let me invite you
to take your copy of it and turn with me
to one Samuel chapter two, back
to one Samuel two in the Old Testament,
continuing this sermon series through this book.
Just as a way of reminder that
Israel has been settled in the land for a little while,
but they were a pretty disorganized bunch of tribes,
only loosely connected by their religious heritage
and the religious practices.
Yet as they let sin
and false idols creep into their lives, the society began
to deteriorate, even to the point
where the highest priests in the land
were sitting blatantly publicly.
Everybody knew it so it could feel like God was absent.
But actually he wasn't because he was working
through a barren, yet faithful woman named Hannah
to bring about life, to breathe life back into his people
through the gift of a son to her named Samuel, that one
that she prayed for, and the one that she turned around
and gave back to God.
But what we're gonna come to today is how God responded
to the high priest family's sin.
H how did they, did they get away with it or,
or what was the process of how they were gonna hand?
What did God do to break through the silence,
to correct the wrongs, to reset worship in Israel?
What did God do?
And then the the follow up question is, how is any
of this relevant for us today?
It is just a good history lesson is what? What is this like?
Why does it matter to us? What happens
here in these two chapters?
Well, we're gonna see some similarities in our lives today,
but I also want you to know
that we're gonna see our savior in this.
So hang with me on this, but first, what did we do?
Well, what did God do with the pervasive sin in Eli
and his sons, those priests that were sending blatantly?
What did God do with them? Well,
God installed a new line of priests.
Like that's what he did. He, he said, you're done.
I'm gonna install a new line of priests.
In fact, you'll see it here as we get into the text.
First Samuel two, starting in verse 27,
There came a man of God to Eli.
I remember Eli was the high priest
and said to him, thus says the Lord.
So this is now God speaking.
Did I indeed reveal myself to the house
of your father when they were in Egypt,
subject to the house of Pharaoh?
Did I choose him out of all the tribes of Israel
to be my priest, to go up to my altar, to burn incense,
to wear an epha before me?
I gave to the house of your father all my offerings
by fire from the people of Israel.
Why then do you scorn my sacrifices
and my offerings that I commanded for my dwelling?
And honor your sons above me
by fattening yourselves on the choices parts
of every offering of my people, Israel.
Now the man of God speaks,
therefore the Lord, the God
of Israel declares God is speaking again.
I promised that your house
and the house of your father should go
in and out before me forever.
But now the Lord declares far be it from me.
For those who honor me, I'll honor.
Those who despise me shall be lightly esteemed.
Behold, the days are coming when I will cut off your
strength and the strength of your father's house.
So there will not be an old man in your house.
Then in distress, you will look
with envious eye on all the prosperity
that shall be bestowed on Israel.
There shall not be an old man in your house forever.
The only one of you whom I shall not cut off from my altars
shall be spared to weep his eyes out to grieve his heart.
And all the descendants of your house
shall die by the sword of men.
This that shall come upon your two sons Hof,
and Phineas shall be the sign to you.
Both of them shall die on the same day.
And I will raise up for myself a faithful priest
who shall do according to what is in my heart, my mind.
I'll build him a sure house.
He should go in and out before my anointed forever.
And everyone who is left in your house shall come
to implore him for a piece of silver or a loaf of bread.
She'll say, please put me in one of the priests places
that I may eat a mor soul of bread.
So what's even happening here?
Well, back in Exodus, what this guy's referring to is
that Aaron and his family had received God's blessings
of becoming the priests of the nation.
That means they got to go to the altar.
They meant they got to share in the meals
that would come from the sacrifices.
They got to wear the special clothes, they got to do all of
that because they were given the blessing of being priests.
Yet this man of God looks at Eli, the priest
and his sons who are in line
to be the priest for getting he.
He calls him out for getting fat off of all that stuff.
In fact, the word
for fattening yourselves is the same word used,
translated elsewhere for glory heaviness.
So basically, this man looks at Eli
and he says, you guys are glorifying yourselves instead
of glorifying me as God.
That's what God was saying, you glorify yourself instead
of glorifying me.
And that's the point.
That's why Eli's family was removed
as the line of priests.
Yes, they were sinning, but they were just
saying, God, it's not about you.
It's about us. And that is nothing that a priest
or any leader should ever say.
They viewed God's sacrifices as worthless.
They didn't honor God.
And so they would not flourish as a priest was supposed to.
Instead, they would starve and eventually be desperate.
There wouldn't be very many of 'em left alive, if any.
Well, the only ones that would be left alive
would only be alive.
So they could see what God does with people
who grieve his heart
and their grief, as we said last
week in kind of a funny way.
Their grief would be very great.
Now, the question that naturally comes up here, I mean,
we kind of get this, that of course they shouldn't be
leaders, but the question that comes up here based on the
reading of the text is that it seems like God
changed his mind.
It seems like God changed.
No, actually, he already knew that Eli
and his sons were going to be wicked worthless men.
And it was God's plan all along to install
a new line of priests.
He already had all that working.
But to us, here's the, here's the point to us.
He lets this picture get painted in our lives
that when things like sin come up, they cost us dearly.
That when we turn away from him
and we turn away from his ways, life hurts really bad.
So he's already working it out.
But for us, it seems like something changes based on what?
Based on sin, based on just turning your back on God.
Because how else would we learn?
How else do you learn that the stove is hot
and it'll burn you when you touch it?
Now, hopefully you'll learn from somebody else's mistake,
but hopefully you, it,
it doesn't always work out that way, right?
It's an instructive consequence
that you touch it and it burns you.
This is the same kind of idea here.
It's instructive in such that it teaches us
what we should not do just as much
as we need to learn what to do.
And so Eli's family,
the consequence removal from the priestly line.
But again, God knows God's work in this whole thing.
Did God just leave it empty? No. What's he doing?
Watch this. Look at verse 35 again in this
to Eli, he says, I will raise up for myself a
faithful priest who shall do according to
what is in my heart and in my mind,
and I will build him a sure house, and he shall go in
and out before my anointed forever.
He says, there's, there's gonna be a line of priests
that it works, right?
They're faithful, which is, by the way,
an essential component to the kingship working
as it was supposed to work.
So a priest, a faithful line
of priests was really important.
In fact, we'll see that come up
with David in a couple chapters, how Zadak probably was
who he's referring to here.
But that's part of it.
There's also a lot of Messiah language in that verse.
Did you catch it? There's a portrayal of perfection,
a portrayal of faithfulness, knowing God's mind.
There's a portrayal of, of a certain house,
like a a sure rock foundation.
There's a, there's a picture painted of,
of a forever priest, right?
So, so there's something beyond just humanity here.
There's, there's something looking ahead.
It's actually to what Hebrews four says.
Since then, we have a great high priest
who has passed through the heavens.
Jesus, the son of God, let us hold fast. Our confession.
We don't have a high priest who's unable
to sympathize with our weaknesses.
One who in every respect has been tempted as we are
yet without sin.
Like the only one who's seen God is God himself.
And this one, the faithful one, Jesus, the son of God,
he is perfect, lived a life that
that one Samuel two talks about.
He's going in and out before the Father forever, right?
That's the picture that this verse is ultimately painting.
Jesus is the ultimate, faithful high priest.
But there's also a temporary fulfillment to this as well.
Eli and his sons were being replaced.
They couldn't just leave it empty.
So somebody had to fill the gap.
And it's initially the one who's been contrasted
with Eli's sons the whole time already.
Eli's sons are wicked worthless men.
There's another son that has shown up,
and his heart was right.
His name was Samuel. I remember
that from the very beginning, even before his birth.
Hannah is praying these things. This is the gift he's given.
Hannah's praying these things. Was she praying?
She's praying all of this same kind of stuff
that this new son whose heart was right
before God, is the replacement figure.
We'll get even a more stark contrast
as we move into the next chapter.
This young boy called By God. We'll see this process happen.
The contrast show up.
Just start with verse one,
chapter three, this sets the scene.
Now, the boy, Samuel, remember he's young, was ministering
to the Lord in the presence of Eli.
And the word of the Lord was rare.
In those days, there was no frequent vision.
Now, remember, Samuel's young,
he's a boy serving faithfully in the tabernacle,
but we immediately get a sense of this replacement idea.
Eli is there. Eli was there with his sons.
Eli's there now with this innocence, new son named Samuel.
So we get a picture, again, the contrast,
but we also get a picture of the desolation.
Israel would've felt back then.
You see that the word, the Lord was rare.
They didn't have this. They didn't have, this is God's word.
They didn't have it. They needed people to speak the word
of the Lord under his inspiration.
They didn't have it. They were,
there were few people speaking on behalf of God,
even the supposed priests, Eli's sons who were supposed
to have the ability to hear from God.
Clearly or not.
Verse two adds to the tension.
It says at the time, Eli, whose eyesight had begun
to grow dim so that he could not see was lying down in
his own place.
This is a physical representation of what was happening
inside of Eli.
His eyesight was dimming. He was unable to see God anymore.
And what did he, we've already seen this from him, right?
What did he think Hannah was doing? Hannah's praying.
Eli, the supposed priest,
hearing from God, Hannah's praying.
And she, he thinks she's drunk.
He can't even understand that we're about
to see it even more, that Eli is fading away.
Look at verse three. The lamp of God had not yet gone out,
meaning God really wasn't done yet with them.
And Samuel was lying down in the temple of the Lord
where the Ark of God was.
Then the Lord called Samuel,
and Samuel said, here I am.
And he ran to Eli. He said, here I am you. You called me.
But Eli said, I did not call lie down again.
And so Samuel went and laid down,
and the Lord called again, Samuel Samuel Rosen went to Eli
and said, here I am for you called me.
But Eli said, I did not call my son. Lie down again.
Now, verse seven. Now, Samuel did not yet know the Lord,
and the word of the Lord had not yet been revealed to him.
So you track that, right?
Samuel thinks Eli's calling his name,
and so a faithful servant.
He's like, oh, Eli, what do you need? Man?
It's the middle of the night. What do you need?
But Samuel didn't recognize.
Eli clearly didn't understand,
but even Samuel did not recognize God's voice
because he hadn't heard it yet.
It was rare. He hadn't heard it. He didn't know God.
It says, now, if you read carefully,
that might ring a bell for us.
Do you remember what one Samuel two verse 12 said
about Eli's sons?
He's worthless men. Of course, it says similarly,
they did not know the Lord.
And here, almost the same phrasing about Samuel,
but there's a critical difference.
Did you catch it? Go look at it again. Read it carefully.
Chapter three, verse seven, with Samuel, it says,
Samuel did not yet know the Lord.
In fact, that word is original language. It's in there.
We're not reading that into it. It's in there.
Samuel did not yet know the Lord.
Eli's sons didn't know the Lord.
It's setting up an assumption
that this son will be different than Eli's sons were.
That he will eventually know the Lord.
He will eventually become that faithful priest
that we saw in chapter two.
Eli's sons. They're already done.
So look at what happened, starting in verse eight.
And the Lord called Samuel again the third time,
and he arose and went to Eli
and said, here I am for you, called me.
Then Eli perceived that the Lord was calling the boy.
Eli finally caught on.
Finally, finally could hear after three tries.
Now, verse nine. Therefore, Eli said to Samuel, go lie down,
and if he calls you, you shall say, speak Lord
for your servant hears.
So Samuel went and laid down in his place, and the Lord came
and stood calling us.
At other times, Samuel, Samuel
and Samuel said, speak for your servant.
Hears. Then the Lord said to Samuel, behold, I'm about
to do a thing in Israel at which the two ears of everyone
who hears it will tingle on that day.
I will fulfill against Eli
and all that I've spoken concerning his
house from beginning to end.
I declare to him, I'm about to punish his house forever
for the iniquity that he knew,
because his sons were blaspheming.
God. He did not restrain them.
Therefore, I swear the house of Eli, that the iniquity
of Eli's house shall not be atoned for by sacrifice
or offering forever, meaning they're done.
Samuel lay until morning.
Then he opened the doors of the house of the Lord,
which he did every day.
And Samuel was afraid to tell the vision to Eli naturally.
But Eli called Samuel and said, Samuel, my son.
And he said, here I am. Same way.
It just worked out that night before.
And Eli said, what was it that he told you?
Do not hide it from me. May God do so to you
and more also if you hide anything from me,
of all that he told you.
So Samuel told him everything hid nothing from him,
and Eli said, it is the Lord.
Let him do what seems good to him.
So a total of four times God calls to Samuel.
But the fourth time did you see something was different
about it, right?
Verse 10, it says, God came
and stood like in the room.
Just, just think about this, the infinite sovereign
God came into this little boy's room.
Now, it wasn't to scare him like solely right?
Walking into the room like surprise, like not
to scare Samuel.
That's not the point of this.
It was to draw near to him.
Just come close to Samuel.
Isn't that amazing? But but isn't that like God too?
'cause Samuel is sleeping, staying,
working in the very location
where the most wicked things in all
of Israel were happening.
Like in the midst of all of the junk, all of the carnage
and sin by Eli and his sons right there.
God shows up and meets with Samuel right there.
He came close. He shared his presence with this young boy.
'cause he was calling him to himself.
Listen, just, this is a side note.
Don't let all the junk
around us keep us from drawing near to our father.
Listen, God is not concerned about all the political drama,
all the wars in the world.
He, he's not fretting over your extended family issues
that just keep coming up, right?
He, he's not. He, he cares for you and for me.
In the middle of all that, if you are his child,
he wants to come near to you
and bring peace with his presence.
Even in all that, don't let that stuff keep you from him.
Don't let that stuff distract you from him.
Eli and his sons were unfaithful priests.
And so what God did, he installed a new line of priests
through this servant hearted boy
with a ready, faithful heart.
So what Luke 14 reminds us, everyone
who exalts himself will be humbled,
but everyone who humbles himself will be exalted.
Eli's sons humbled. Samuel was lifted up.
Well, here's what happens next in this narrative, it's,
it's very similar actually to Jesus' early
life in the Gospels.
We don't see much like things kind
of fast forward from early life, childhood Jesus,
and all of a sudden he's 30.
Like what happened there?
It's pretty similar with Samuel actually.
We don't see much between Samuel's
childhood and his adulthood.
It's what you'll see here starting in verse 19
of chapter three, and Samuel grew.
That's it. That's all we get.
So all of a sudden, he's an adult now
because the Lord was with him
and let none of his words fall to the ground.
And all Israel from Dan to Bes Sheba knew
that Samuel was established as a prophet of the Lord.
And the Lord appeared again at Shiloh,
for the Lord revealed himself to Samuel at Shiloh
by the word of the Lord.
And the word of Samuel came to all Israel.
So what God had promised to do to Eli
and his sons had not happened yet.
We'll get there next week. But what we start
to see is a glimpse of this new day
that God was bringing in Israel, right?
Things are different now.
Things are starting to happen,
and it was through a miraculous birth.
Did you catch that Baron, Hannah brings about Samuel, right?
The miraculous birth through
that God was again among his people.
God was again speaking, God was again meeting
with his people at the tabernacle again.
And he did it all through this man named Samuel.
Now, actually, we've seen I, I did kind
of joke about Samuel grew.
We've seen a thread of Samuel growing
throughout the narrative already.
Chapter two, verse 21.
He grew in the presence of the Lord.
Chapter two, verse 26 actually says it this way,
the boy Samuel continued to grow both in stature
and in favor with the Lord and also with man.
So Samuel was growing up physically as children do,
but he was also growing spiritually
because God had a plan for his life, something
that he knew was coming.
He wanted Samuel prepared for it,
and ultimately he was to perform this
quasi priest role for a little bit.
But more than that, what we see in Samuel was that God
initiated a new authority in prophets.
This was the shift that they needed a priest
to stand before God
and kind of do that ceremonial role, holy kind of role.
Yes, but they also needed prophets
and a new authority came through those.
Now, Moses was a prophet.
There might've been a couple others throughout the history
of Israel, but Samuel was really the
first prominent prophet.
He shows up and he has this role.
So we need to ask the question,
okay, what's the role of the prophet?
What do they do? What actually did God do
with this in the new authority?
Where did that authority come from?
Well, we learn a lot from it just right
here in these couple of verses.
First, we discovered that the prophet's authority only came
through the word of God.
It only came through God's word.
This new authority was through God's word.
It's all over this section.
Actually like verse 19, look at this.
The Samuel grew, the Lord was with him
and let none of his words fall to the ground.
Why were, why was Samuel's word so powerful?
Because the Lord was with him.
And then in verse 21, the Lord revealed himself to Samuel
by the word of the Lord.
That's why at this point,
whenever this is all of Israel from Dan North
to be Sheba in the South, the whole population,
they all knew that Samuel had been
established as a prophet of the Lord.
They all knew that he was speaking God's words.
That's what they could understand,
because this was a new day.
It used to be. Remember chapter three verse one.
The word of the Lord was rare.
Now, by the end of this, Samuel,
he's speaking God's word and everybody knows it.
Something has been different.
Faithful ministry back then.
But listen, it's true just as much today,
faithful ministry only comes through hearing
and speaking God's very words.
That's where the authority lie back then.
That's where it lays today as much
it's gotta be based on God's words alone, which is
what he was speaking regularly as a prophet.
But it wasn't just to himself. It was towards God's people.
That's what this new authority was for.
It was through God's word to God's people.
He was called to be with God. How cool that would be.
But that wasn't it. There was something more.
It says none of his spoken words fell to the ground.
Everyone knew he was a prophet, meaning
what he was doing was he was speaking words to people.
They were coming true people could identify
he was a true prophet.
He was speaking truth and encouragement.
Then chapter four, the word of Samuel came to all Israel.
This is all setting us up for the whole book of Samuel.
How he plays this role of God's mouthpiece
to God's people.
That Samuel speaks the very words of God,
encouragement when they needed it,
but also rebuke when they needed it, correction,
teaching when they needed it.
He was receiving God's word and speaking God's word.
He had to do both sides of that.
He couldn't just do encouraging.
He had to correct as needed.
So again, unlike
before, now everybody knows God's speaking again.
He's with us, praise God
through God's word to God's people.
But there was one more aspect to this.
We need to see this prophetic authority was
that it accompanied God's king.
God was doing this new work, new authority,
Now, you may be perceptive and you say, we're not there yet.
We don't have kings yet here in one Samuel
that's coming in like chapter eight or later, right?
So how, how do you tie it together here, watch this.
Go back to chapter two, verse 35.
This was said about the priests.
Remember, I will raise up
for myself a faithful priest who shall do according to
what is in my heart, in my mind.
I will build him a sure house.
He shall go in and out before my anointed forever.
That phrase, my anointed
is a common phrase in the Old Testament for the king.
Like if you're looking for a tie, it's right there.
The priest or the prophet,
or maybe both, would anoint the king on God's behalf.
He would say, here's who the king is,
and they would anoint with oil and have a big ceremony.
That's, we'll see it later in one Samuel.
And even though this is prior to that one,
king Saul being anointed, there's something happening here
that's foreshadowing what's going to come,
because there's a shift in this book
that's happening towards a monarchy, towards that kingship.
And even though it was not God's desire for them
to have a king, he was their king.
He shall reign over them. He didn't want that.
He was not surprised by it either.
And what he did is he set up rules
and regulations to limit the power
of the king when it happened,
but also to keep that king holy.
The prophet was who he used to do that a prophet was
who would stand with the king
and speak God's word, both corrective
and encouraging all of that to the king and the king.
The monarchy would not work without a
prophet standing there with him.
In fact, go read the rest of the Old Testament.
You read the story of the kings,
and every time it went south is when they said, no,
I'm not listening to you, prophet.
And they just disregarded the words of God
through the prophet that God had assigned to speak the words
of God, and they walked their own way.
And everything goes terribly.
It does not work without a prophet.
And Samuel was the first one.
Samuel was the one who filled that role first.
Now, the question I asked
before the question we need to ask right now,
what do we do with all this?
I mean, we could easily sit here
and be like, man, that was 30 minutes
of a good history lesson.
That's gonna set us up for the rest of the book. Awesome.
What do? What do we do with that? Like it, it's natural.
You read the Bible. Sometimes you kind of get there like,
oh, okay, great.
What do we do with this? Now?
Part of it is to set up the rest,
the call background of Samuel.
That's important as we go forward. Yes.
But then the question, is it merely to remind us
of the tragedy of sin and the blessing of obedience?
Okay, well, that that's part of it. Yeah, that can be good.
Or is it mainly to like spur us on, like Samuel, listen
to the call of God.
You find the call of God in your life
and you serve him with all you got.
Ah, it's, it's a bit of a stretch.
But yeah, you could, you could make that.
I think for us today,
we're not in the theocracy that Israel was.
We're followers of Christ now.
So the question we need to ask is how do we see our savior,
our redeemer through this?
Is it just history? Or how do we see Jesus?
How does this lift our eyes to our savior?
Well, lemme take you on a journey towards that.
Remember how a couple weeks ago I said, Samuel is a type
of Christ, meaning we see things in Samuel's
life, that foreshadows aspects we'll
understand about the Messiah.
So there's pieces of Samuel's life that point us to Jesus.
Even something as simple as chapter two, verse 26.
Remember the boy Samuel continued to grow both in stature
and in favor with the Lord and also with man.
That might sound familiar
because Luke chapter two, verse 52 says this,
Jesus increased in wisdom and in stature
and in favor with God
and man
sounds familiar.
I think Luke was making an intentional connection back
to Samuel, that he was linking Jesus
with Samuel.
'cause just think about what we saw in Samuel,
even just today, right?
Eli and his sons were rejected from the
priesthood who fills the gap.
Samuel, as God installs new
authority in prophets.
Who was the first one? Samuel.
And then later God would anoint the first king of Israel.
Who did he use to do that?
Who would be the one to go in and out before the king
and speak God's truth to the King Samuel?
So Samuel was a faithful priest, a faithful prophet.
He was also involved with the kingship.
He was all of those things.
The problem was he was limited in all of those things
because what did God want?
He wanted a sure house.
He wanted a forever presence before him.
He wanted someone to speak God's words eternally.
Samuel couldn't do that.
In fact, no human born of a man
and a woman could ever do that.
We're limited. Every one of us. No one could.
So what Samuel's life does is he points us
to the truly faithful priest, to the truly faithful prophet,
to the one true king whose name is Jesus the Messiah.
When we look at Samuel's life, we can look forward
and we can see Jesus, the one who on our behalf, went
behind the curtain so he could rip it open by dying
on the cross and shedding his blood to forgive us
and give us access to God as the priest we need.
His life points us to the true very word
of God, not just who speaks the words of God,
who is the word of God as the prophet we need,
and Samuel's life points us to the one
who carries the government of the world on his shoulders,
the king we need.
So yes, we are praising God.
For Samuel, how he got God used him
to reset Israel in some massive ways, even
to anoint King David
and that line through which the Messiah would come one day,
God did all that through Samuel,
but in the end, Jesus is the priest we need.
Jesus is the prophet we need.
Jesus is the king we need because he
and only he can reign forever and ever.
That's what we need, church. That's why we sing.
That's why we live, because he is who he is
and He's done what He's done.
That's what Samuel's life points us to.